اطلق عليها قريه الكراسي المتحركه معظم
العائلات في هذه القريه الهنديه لديها شخص
او اكثر يعاني من اعاقه ما شلل الاطفال
العمى التشوهات الخلقيه وغيرها من
الاعاقات جائعه هنا بشده والسبب مياه
الشرب ماساه انسانيه تعيشها قريه التجاره
عن واقعه في ولايه بنجاب السكان الفقراء
في هذه البقعه الموبوءه يعتقدون ان مياه
الشرب لوثت بسبب انتشار المصانع والمدابغ
في المنطقه دراسات قام بها باحثون قالت ان
المياه هنا شديده السميه وتحتوي على
مستويات عاليه من الرصاص واليورانيوم هو
الزرني لافتات كثيره وضعتها الحكومه
للتحذير من شرب المياه الملوثه لكن ان
بديل للسكان الفقراء عن هذه المياه حتى مع
يقينهم بانها مصدر امراديوم
[موسيقى]